grosse révolution chez apple c'est la
première fois qu'ils sortent une montre
qui vient concurrencer garmin l'apple
watch ultra c'est un monstre boîtier en
titane verre en saphir un bouton
d'action qui vient d'apparaître 36
heures d'autonomie jusqu'à 60 euros
maximum un deuxième haut parleurs pour
bien entendre tout ce qui se passe trois
micros résistants de -20 degrés jusqu'à
55 degrés pouvait faire la plongée avec
bref c'est le nom qui est destiné aux
aventuriers les plus extrêmes ou
sportifs les plus ardus et qui vient
concurrencer en frontal les mondes de
garmin et d'autres constructeurs pour de
l'outdoor très poussée alors elle est
pas cadeau
999 euros mais le produit est très
exigeant et très sexy ça vient vraiment
compléter cette gamme d apple watch est
pas ce que vous en pensez et ce qu'elles
pourraient vous tenter mark et moi tout
ça en bas dans les commentaires et puis
pour tout savoir de la tutelle je vous
invite à venir vous abonner